[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
but essentially you get a micro needling
which is like little tiny needles and
then it brings your blood to the surface
which is like really healthy for your
skin and then they can inject all sorts
of stuff into your face yeah but
what are they putting in there listen it
is an extraction
from a um a a
a piece of skin
uh that came from
a young person
um
far far away and they somehow figured
out how to extract it's foreskin from a
korean baby
[Laughter]
that's real she's putting korean baby
penises in her face and there are korean
babies thousands of them going where is
it where's my penis
where's the rest of my body
it's right here
it's my cheekbones
how do you say penis in korean yeah how
do you say penis you know if i i don't
gochu
right and i'm going to tell you this
right now yeah if i was one of those
korean babies yeah when i get older
i'm coming to l.a
i'm knocking on the her door yeah want
it back
just grab her face get out take it out i
want it back how about this we can start
your a-a-i-a-a-p-i yeah p.s no
i'm that's the new campaign no more
corruption asians being violated against
that's the that's the real crime because
korean specific no more korean foreskin
facials yeah no more korean foreskins
no more korean foreskin facials no more
korean foreskin faith dude if you don't
want to participate in an aapi yeah and
stop asian hey if you don't want to be
here get the [ __ ] out of here jules
no more korean foreskin facials no more
korean foreskin
more korean facials
special there we go i mean it's like
minimal you don't have to go to the
protest okay let me ask another question
about this about this i don't know what
all i know is this clip okay but let me
just ask a question so
i imagine you're in korea
i'm a christian you're a surgeon
you deliver babies your doctor got it
right baby's born you clip the [ __ ]
force again
whose
idea is it
at first to go maybe this
could go
well you know what so you know what's so
funny what happened he clipped the
foreskin and then he put it on his
cheeks one of the one of the surgeons
and one as a joke as a joke everyone
laughed and their nurses go skin look
beautiful
[Laughter]
he put a bunch of little baby foreskins
all over his face as a joke yeah right
oh look at me look at me right
here everybody look at me right and
and maybe everyone's wait what is it
buffalo bill who is it that's yeah yeah
yeah yeah so he puts it on his facebook
and he's doing a little funny
look at me look at me everybody look at
me right and then and then everyone's
kind of bit and then one nurse goes hey
you look
young how come you don't see many asian
people with down syndrome
and now you're about i'm going to answer
it with the most racist thing
because you're setting me up to say
something racist
scientific i'm gonna answer this to you
right
sometimes you can't tell with koreans
you wanna [ __ ] with my money huh
okay
we have the same
amount as you white people
it's just that sometimes you just can't
okay
and if that if you wanted me to say that
you set me up right and so everyone
listens right now yeah you know what
you're doing wait what are you saying
you're saying what i'm saying what kind
of people
what kind of people what koreans are
look like what they look like what down
syndrome people right so basically
here's how this is what happened right
she wants to say that
i don't know she wants to see that i
don't want to she can't so i don't want
to she has success
so the i say it and then she can go
there we go
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you when i first saw
you you know what i thought
i'd be honest because i was being honest
no no joke i said
that's that crazy guy
that gets naked all the time at the
comedy store that's literally what i
thought to myself that's that crazy guy
that gets naked at the comedy store i
won't do it again again what
when do you get naked
naked all the time when all the time no
no no don't look google it don't google
it you won't find anything and this
won't be on a tv show
if it's performing too it doesn't matter
oh my god i won't find it the first
eight pictures are of you on stage
performing
the same thing as a tv show
no
yes performing this is on tom green's
show performing
performing this is on at a radio station
performing
performing bobby lee naked on stage
performing
this is you at your house performing
another performing but i love how you
say i don't get naked look at how many
naked photos come up it's almost insane
it's almost absurd how many come on have
you ever seen that yeah you do you do
all right let me show it to you again
it ain't that small pull the [ __ ]
camera off to the side
i mean you know yeah it's all right
that's that's it dude no hold on you you
have to deal with that now
would it kill him to trim a little bit
no i go to the airport and it's
sebastian monoskalko's was at the
airport tom was there i think dan cook
was there
and you know we were supposed to get our
own tickets
so my manager abby juju
she's jewish she wants to save money so
she always gives me coach
always she's like honey
it's it's not a big deal there's no
difference
right yeah yeah so
now i remember yeah yeah so then
these guys get first class yeah so i'm
i'm talking to them in the you know you
know
yeah
giggling their first class and they all
leave and i'm like now i blush
and i'm going oh my god i gotta walk by
them right
and you know let me say something
walking by i don't know how christ felt
when he was like
you know holding the thing and yeah
throwing rocks but
it felt you know similar yeah i i would
assume the only thing i regretted in
that moment yeah was that i wasn't
already better friends with you because
then i would have enjoyed it
you know yeah did i just feel sorry for
him at that point no like i cuz with a
comic you already like they let you know
what kind of person they are so there's
some comics who would have given off the
vibe of like don't make this a thing
yeah and you kind of like if you can
pick up on people's yeah you know body
language and stuff you're like all right
you'd be like but he was playing into
like he was talking about it like i'm
still embarrassed and i was like that's
awesome
you should be yeah yeah you know you're
a piece of [ __ ] go back there yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's what it was yeah
they were like booing did you boo i
think they were booze and then yeah you
told the flight attendant to bring you
stuff yeah go give him this pillow yeah
no you came back and threw a pillow on
me
he took a first-class pillow and he goes
hey use that you know what i mean and it
was just
so embarrassing yeah my neighbor was a
was a chef named roy choi roy choi
started
he was my next door neighbor and our
kids are the same age
yeah yeah
i think so
are you friends i love them
i love you roy
does anyone know what happened over the
weekend does it okay what are you gonna
say before we even get up i might stop
you the biggest thing all right well i'm
stopping you
what that does has no
business
in in this podcast anymore i feel like
it's my right to tell this story it's my
story to tell guess why what you guys
cuz i didn't [ __ ] put your poop in a
doggy bag didn't i whoa
it's my story now as if i have to do the
cleanup it's my story to tell
i have to know the story now please tell
me
tell us bobby please tell your story you
tell them
so i get a phone call i get a phone call
he's coming home from from warner
brothers and i got a frantic phone call
he's like
that's not something's so bad
oh yeah he went to terrace mexico which
is great food by the way
no there's a new one on it
and i get a phone call and he's like
babe something really bad just happened
in my head the first thing i was like oh
my god he's finally run over somebody
and like that's what happened because of
his driving
wildlife
dude his driving's insane yeah so then i
was like [ __ ] what happened
and he's like i need help i'm downstairs
in the garage and there's poo everywhere
and i'm like how is there poo everywhere
it turns out that he was on the freeway
on route to come home
stuck in traffic
couldn't make it out of the exit pulled
over into the side of the freeway
climbed over into the back seat
and took [ __ ] in the back seat
do you like dad
that's something dad did
you just look dead
[ __ ] like a man
what's steve doing
it's just like father i can't believe it
you're just like dad man
that's exactly what dad would do let me
tell you a story all day
my dad was driving did you describe this
van
because he'd put uh his merchandise in
it
and then he was on some kind of
freelancer highway
and he couldn't stop either but he did
it on a paper plate at least
he did it right on the scene
disgusting man and then he comes he
comes running upstairs
you're a goddamn animal man
you need help bro and can i tell you
what happened
afterwards the beast
so he tells
oh he he comes up and i see his butt as
he runs into the bathroom and it's just
diarrhea all over his pants
so then i'm thinking he couldn't even
take his [ __ ] pants off
[ __ ] it's his health
no we need to talk up no seriously he's
into his pants
and then into the car seat and then i
said
listen to this steve
oh no
and then
and then
i said okay fine i'll take it to the car
wash in the morning but i was like you
know what i'm not gonna do it i'm gonna
have jenna do it
because you know jenna needs the money
and i so i told her you better give her
500
she came in in a hazmat suit she i swear
to god she came in fully suited up but
then he goes
it was fifty dollars
[Laughter]
dude
50.
it was 50.
oh lord and then he said
he said i tried to
i tried to clean it with a spray as best
as i could so jenna should be fine dry
so jenna basically
had but then that's not the worst part
on the way there
on the way there jenna checked the back
seat because she was like something
smells really bad are you sure that he
cleaned it with spray
and she goes back there and there's two
big turds that kind of just roll have
been rolling around in the back seat
camouflaged into this yeah
so she then has to
she then ha she calls me she's like oh
my god i don't know what to do but
there's still poo rolling around back
there
and so i she had to pick it up she had
to use her hand she had to raw hand it
i'm worried about his health
there's so much he's going to get a
colonoscopy
there's so much meat
korean barbecue and just meat
i know his body i am his brother
he's nuts when you have diarrhea can i
ask a question sure
just go ahead a curiosity yeah so when
you have diarrhea right do you uh does
it burn
oh my god it burns and cramping i get i
mean i get intense cramping yeah and it
burns
i hear me too but my husband doesn't get
the cramping do you think he's so fat
you don't know where the cramp is
because it's such a big area yeah i mean
it could be here or there i'm all in
chicago
the grizzly animal
in chicago your mom
it's funny
that grizzly animal
don't don't talk about my mother
well it's just a joke
relax yeah my mother's very pretty she's
a beautiful woman unlike your cross-eyed
mother
don't you you don't have to [ __ ] get
spit i'm not bobby mudder
i'm i'm bobby mom
you're so [ __ ] mean dude all these
asians that are in entertainment their
parents ain't want them to do that let's
be honest yeah like being an actor
that's not what your parents are like
hoping you would be when you grow up so
they're renegades as well
but because you're too rent you're too
much of a renegade they're like oh no
but that's a little too far he shits in
the back of his prius they don't want
that [ __ ] no that's understandable
i'm okay with that like you should be
shunned by the community
like chinese people just stop [ __ ]
on the street and here you are
an asian sitting in a prius
not on purpose by accident what happened
you didn't even drink i got no excuse i
know i just have this i i i smoke
cigarettes and i drink a lot of coffee
andrew right i have this certain urgent
i have a certain urge to take a [ __ ]
every once in a while uncontrollably
traffic
park outside of my dermatologist because
he would rather [ __ ] inside the car than
outside and occur oh my god bro on la
cienega you can't [ __ ] outside of los
angeles it's the busiest street in l.a
yeah so you [ __ ] in your prius that's
[ __ ] in the prius
in a bag in a bag in a bag oh yeah seat
yeah
i didn't think you shouldn't [ __ ] see
yeah yeah
but he has shot in the seat before i
have done that too yeah
[Laughter]
so many stories but here's the thing
okay
that
wow what
what i i'm sorry i mean you just never i
never never imagined you playing with
children
i'm glad you didn't the way you just put
it
let me ask you something right now and
this is a real question dude
if um
if like people in the this country had a
disease right and they're all what's my
favorite disease no the only and the
only way to cure it is if you suck my
dick would you suck my dick
i'm talking about billions of people bro
what billions people what what do you
mean what well you said like
basically you said would you suck my
dick
into people
i was like what does he mean why no i'm
just saying though there's some sort of
some disease in the country right do you
really have a dick but you have like a
kazoo
yeah
would you would you suck it though to
save millions of people's lives or what
i mean
here's what i would do i wouldn't suck
it yeah but if uh someone else sucked it
you know and it was late late at night i
might smell their breath really fast
oh you would do that yeah i would hope
that i wouldn't hear that that would
cure probably a hundred people maybe
yeah but as long as i'm one of those
hundred then that's how it means we'll
ask you ask the reverse would i suck
your dick for a [ __ ] for billions
yeah what do they ask me would you suck
my dick for a little for
for 70 80 bucks what
that's it yeah 70 80 bucks save the
world well you're not gonna just give me
80. can you just give me 80. okay
yeah wow yeah
round it out to 100. what about for a
cheat code on uh on that bejeweled game
you play or whatever
what about from mystery levels would you
suck dick from mystery
lila was so difficult to get
what do you mean oh to like get as a
girlfriend yeah i mean it was i i was
like
i might have people that
get this one
yeah first of all she's anonymous
what none of us thought so
[ __ ] you when i first saw kalila i was
like and i met her not when i saw her
how about this take away just her that
she's pretty yeah when i saw that she
was so cool and nice and sweet yeah
i i was a little annoyed yeah yeah
but that was your girlfriend earlier i
said that i sucked a guy's dick did i
say that yes you did okay that's okay
nothing wrong with that i feel like it's
been weird ever since then no no what
was what was worse the dick or [ __ ]
what [ __ ] like when you're just
licking a girl's [ __ ]
i they dig for sure
i'm not gay dude
yeah but i was thinking about it the
other day have you ever sucked a dick no
you've never nope not even once no you
think about it
but i was i was thinking about a couple
like last week for girls it just must be
like
hard skin like that's all like it
doesn't what like it doesn't it doesn't
taste like anything like if you take it
yeah that's why
i found a therapist
a korean guy
dr choi yeah
and uh i wanted to we had fun doing my
dream
um
i wrote down the dream the day the night
before yesterday yeah i want you to read
it off there's i just just
doubt
i want you to analyze um just the notes
that i had about my dream read it out
loud into the mic
dream number one
tunnel i had to walk through
on the ground were centipedes
and even
scorpions got to a luxury school
it's because this is got to a luxury
high school
walked into
men's shower noticed that the male
females were
you walked through a men's shower notice
that the male and females were combined
they were like genetically or like
mutated
all alone in the dark
i
had an apartment
[Music]
and his mom
[Laughter]
i mean listen to me man you think that
like
being the way i look i was killing it in
the 90s
i wasn't
because
imagine this look at this body yeah you
didn't have this body right okay you
didn't have you know you're why you got
to make it like that i don't do anything
i mean that's what i'm thinking but
don't
i don't but you don't have what you know
what i have i think that you're wrong
because i don't care what you you're not
gonna it's not what i thought i know but
you're not gonna believe this but i
sincerely from the get-go found you to
find you attractive all right i mean i
also grew up around a lot of koreans
yeah she's like in high school i would
have dated dude no you wouldn't have
dated [ __ ] you would have never even
seen me she said
i'm in the woods during lunch
learning crystal meth you made it ugly
oh yeah i [ __ ] up a ton of ugly guys
because i wasn't that cute either when i
first came from the philippines i had a
[ __ ] i wanted you [ __ ] back then you
know what i'm sure tooth to gum ratio it
was i was a mess who else could i
couldn't have had
of that statement she's like of course i
would have dated you i dated other ugly
guys
my brother and i used to go to this spot
on beverly boulevard and it was like
there's no sign it wasn't a korean spa
my brother and i went in there and there
was two guys
just jerking each other off
in there and my brother he goes let's
[ __ ] get out of here
like he got really angry right yeah but
it's like they weren't jerking off on us
well you should you probably left right
i did it like maybe a three minute steam
off to the side well let's pretend like
you're on the tonight show now ready
yeah i'm jimmy fallon all right you
ready yeah
oh i got a good one okay okay okay today
oh you're gonna love this guy you love
this guy this guy's great um this guy
he's on podcast uh right now called
bedford's it's a great one
he's got his broadcasters at tiger belly
also a great one this guy's also on a
game show right now it's awesome he's
selling a show he sold a show this guy
is going to be bigger than he's already
he's already big he's already big ladies
and gentlemen bobby lee bobby lee
hey man hey you [ __ ] white [ __ ]
tarn
if you were to choose
andrew and i
right if you were gay who would you [ __ ]
who would you prefer to [ __ ] me or
andrew
me [ __ ] or me getting [ __ ] up oh
that's a very very good question
very good question oh you [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
you [ __ ]
andrew how much body hair do you have
almost none actually i'm actually i'm
not i'm not hairy at all just answer the
[ __ ] question
yeah but let me think i mean i don't
like hair yeah i think andrew might have
a nice ass yeah
like nice [ __ ] into us but bobby
seems more like
feminine and he has more curves
and i probably want to hold his breasts
i think
i think
i think he'll was your bobby
yeah bobby you got it
you got one i don't give a [ __ ] dude
what you said i won that you have a full
more feminine you want to hold your tits
i love this
i was working the door
so i was working the door at the store
at store and andrew does clay walks up
to me i don't even know him
and he goes hey ching get in the car
he used to call me ching
right he didn't know my name for 10
years
every time ching
and i go my name is bobby no you're
ching i go that's racist he goes no as
chi-ching you got your money
right he tried to switch it up
he flies me first-class i have my
communists for a t-shirt on first class
to las vegas
right and he goes you're going to be my
good luck charm
he loses
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
how long
in in 24 hours it would i never see i
mean imagine having no money and then
what was [ __ ] up about it is the whole
ride over there he was like you're gonna
get ten percent of my winnings
so in my head is if he makes a million
dollars
i'm gonna make a hundred grand
right but now he's down 750
right and he goes go home i went home
and he didn't talk to me for you tell
them what i do at a restaurant if i pay
so if he pays
um i'm taking out some people
let's say you ordered a 65 steak tastes
delicious um you only eat half you want
to take some home to your kids and i'm
paying for it if he's paying for it
you're not allowed to take anything i
like that
i like exactly why i like that i love
mine i like
wrapped up and then bobby just goes yeah
one box no i leave i don't even take it
in fact i've done this before i leave it
on the table
no one can take it i've taken the box
i've secretly packed it in a box and
he's done this to a sandwich of mine
looked at it
smashed my sandwich
so it's now all over the place and then
it's hilarious and the next time you pay
for the meal you can take it home do
whatever you want with it that is so
brilliant i believe
that if i was imprisoned that you would
be really caring you would have tears in
your eyes and you would really care i
don't know if you can do that as an
actor i think that kind of depth
like johnny depp yeah but i'm just
letting you know that
we joked around just now but in real
life i really believe that you would
make me cry and go thank you so much sir
okay you can't do it now i don't think
i might be able to
i don't really let's try it real all
right so i'm gonna be real too because
okay
so here we go is this taped yeah okay
sir
i think they're gonna kill me tomorrow
you can't laugh man you're [ __ ] up
but the way you looked at me it was so
[ __ ] funny
it wasn't funny dude let's do it again
sorry not funny you're gonna cut let's
do a scene all right but the way you
looked at me was so sincere it made me
laugh so hard so let's start all right
all right yeah that's what i'm supposed
to do you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] all
right just look away from me and turn to
me like that when i say my line that's
what i i know
i get another shot at it
the white dude i don't know i don't know
if it was your brother or whatever he
goes i'm gonna hang you you [ __ ]
tomorrow you flat-faced [ __ ]
i'm scared
time for you to die you little [ __ ]
snap pee
[Music]
[Music]
you